sobre todo el electorado de la Florida
donde recordemos fue reelecto en las
últimas elecciones al estado por Más de
19 puntos donde santis tiene 44 años se
educó en la universidad de hielo y de
Harvard en leyes después fue congresista
por Orlando un Distrito electoral
cercano a la ciudad de Orlando en la
Florida y siendo congresista fundó el
caucos de la extrema derecha en Estados
Unidos sus políticas son radicales y muy
polémicas en cuanto a inmigración en
cuanto al aborto en cuanto a políticas
de género Precisamente en cuanto a
inmigración ha habido muchas críticas
recientes porque sus políticas radicales
frente a este tema han hecho que muchos
inmigrantes indocumentados se vayan del
estado y esto ha hecho que la el negocio
de la propiedad raíz y la construcción
pues se haya encarecido y ha recibido
varias críticas al respecto ron de
santis llega entonces carrera
presidencial como el principal
contrincante de Donald Trump Donald
Trump de hecho ya reaccionó en redes
sociales atacando al precandidato
presidencial de la Florida diciendo que
no tiene personalidad que es un
discípulo de otro congresista llamado y
que simplemente no es un republicano de
pura cepa además hay que Resaltar
también que en las últimas encuestas
Donald Trump va por encima en cuanto a
intención de voto de los republicanos y
el segundo que le sigue es precisamente
y Cristóbal usted mismo lo mencionaba
Donald Trump es un poco el protagonista
de esta carrera dentro del partido
republicano Pero qué otras personas han
oficializado ya su candidatura
ya son siete precandidatos republicanos
el primero de ellos obviamente es el
expresidente Donald Trump lo sigue en
cuanto a intención de votos por las
encuestas recientes
gobernador de la Florida y antiguo
congresista pero está también Larry
Elder que es un periodista O al menos
tiene su propio podcast y programa de
radio está en Miki Halley que fue
embajadora de las Naciones Unidas en la
administración de Donald Trump también
está hasta Joaquín que es que fue
gobernador del estado de Arkansas y
vipec ramasahui que es un empresario y
autor de libros que también se presentó
a las a esta campaña por la candidatura
republicana y finalmente recordemos esta
semana también se presentó a esta
carrera por la candidatura republicana
Tim Scott el senador afroamericano de
Carolina del Sur Y pues obviamente
este último completa esta lista de siete
precandidatos hasta ahora pero se espera
que pence y se espera que también el ex
gobernador del estado de Nueva Jersey se
presenten a esta a esta contienda por la
no por la nominación republicana que
pues va a ser bastante bastante reñida